what's the connection between fire
cooking and the eating of meat
do you which came first do you think uh
humans
starting to enjoy the eating of meat
or the the the invention of fire and the
use of fire for cooking i think that
fire increased the using of meat but um
but the fact that chimpanzees uh really
like to hunt and kill meat as do bonobos
uh certainly puts us in so they
those two species have a common ancestor
with us going six seven million years
ago and it was from that common ancestor
that you get the australopithecine line
it's very likely therefore astrologians
were eating meat when they could get it
which wouldn't be very often because
they wouldn't be very
good sprinters but nevertheless they
would occasionally be able to get some
meat and i bet they loved it all the
time and basically all primates like
meat if they can get it almost all of
them
but i think fire would have been very
important um
for a couple of reasons
uh one is that once you eat fire once
you eat your food cooked then you're
saving yourself time
by saving yourself time
you can free up
the opportunity to go and hunt more
because hunting is a high risk high gain
activity
there's every risk that you will get
nothing on one particular afternoon that
you go off
looking for opportunities to kill
but it's high gain because when you do
get something
you bring down a kudu then
you've got a serious amount of meat
what did males and females do with the
time they were saving from not having to
chew their food i think that
in the case of males it's very
reasonable to think they spent a greatly
increased amount of time hunting
so chimpanzees
they hunt
maybe two or three times a month and the
average hunt length is 20 minutes
with humans they're
hunting maybe uh 20 times a month and
the average hunt length is six hours
yeah so it's a huge difference yeah
so and that's possible because the time
was available because they were cooking
less chewing more hunting you got it
the other thing is
that
the meat is so much nicer
yeah yeah so when a chimpanzee
kills a monkey and i mean they are so
excited about killing a monkey you know
they are so excited about going into the
hunt and uh when they
make the kill then there's screams
everywhere and some don't like to
seize it and capture it and take it away
from the others and
eventually the strongest one has it and
the others sit around begging and trying
to get some and tear it off and so yeah
they all love it
there are others who he often goes to
the top of a tree
in order to be able to get away from all
of these beggars and scavengers and
while he's there uh drops of blood or
little scraps will fall down to the
bottom and uh the junior members of
society you know the females and young
and that sort of thing um they they are
racing through to find a particular leaf
that's got a drop of blood on it so they
can lick it i mean they love it
but
yes
it takes them a lot of time to chew it i
mean it's the same thing as for cooked
food in general
so
they are getting meats very slowly into
their bodies
and there sometimes comes a time when
they just say i've had enough of this i
need real food and they'll drop the meat
and go off and and eat
fruit again because they can get fruit
into their bodies so much faster than
they can get meat
so once they're cooking that problem is
solved and they can eat the meat so this
is much more readily so i think that
meat eating would become important
for two reasons with cooking so the key
uh not to oversimplify but the key
moments in human history
are with the homo erectus
the discovery of fire and the use of
fire for cooking
and then with uh homo sapiens
the
the beta males
killing off the alpha male so that the
cooperation can exist and cooperation
leads to
communication and language and ideas the
sharing of ideas that kind of thing
well yes the only thing i would modify
on that is that you have to ask
how is it that the beta males were able
to kill the alpha male
right
and we now know that although
chimpanzees do kill males within their
own group sometimes it's not a process
of killing the alpha male it's taking
advantage of opportunity when some male
gets into a bad position but it's not a
systematic ability to kill the alpha
male
and you can see see why you know because
they don't have language
and without language it's very difficult
to know
how confident you can be
of the support of others against a
particular individual within your own
group yes
when you're attacking someone from
another group that problem is solved you
know we all hate the
yes you know
those guys
but
the alpha male has got alliances within
his group
some of those allies might be willing to
to turn against him
some of them might be harboring deep
feelings of resentment
yeah
but how does anyone else know that
so in other words i think that you have
to have some kind of language that is
pretty good
to solve the problems of
gaining confidence
that
five of you say you know or some some
number
um
can trust each other in this final
attack
and you know even nowadays it's it's
difficult uh you know when you mention
stalin
it's like
why was everybody terrified
any dictator that takes control why is
all of us as individuals terrified when
you know there's millions of us
uh that's right and so like that we lack
the language because our basic
psychology of fear overtakes us like who
can we talk to who can we talk to and
not get killed ourselves exactly that's
right but you're yeah do you have this
intuition that some kind of language was
developing
along with this process
of beta males taking over yes yes i mean
once you have
sufficient language to be able to have
the beta males conspiring to kill the
alpha male
then you have selection uh in favor of
uh cooperation and tolerance as we spoke
about and at that point there will be uh
increased ability to communicate and the
language will get richer and better and
better
so yes absolutely positive feedback loop
once you get the situation started
you